Blue Dream it'll give you that lovely
euphoria but of course if you want some
wings Sour Diesel is definitely the way
to go the dizzying number of cannabis
strains each have a unique personality
but how a specific variety reacts within
your body is still largely a scientific
mystery that's partly because marijuana
is still a shade or one drug which makes
it pretty difficult to research evidence
we knew that some of the compounds were
useful now it's time to get serious
about it and to understand what those
compounds are so that we can really put
it to good use a company in Berkeley
California of course is decoding all
those popular strains to unlock the true
potential of cannabis steep hill is a
cannabis analytics plan and what that
means is that we are interested in
identifying basically everything that we
can about cannabis the lab does quality
control for dispensaries that want to be
100% sure that their product is safe it
has four pesticides for instance and
determines if mold or fungus has
infected a sample and then there's the
chemical profiling that we do which is
important to be able to do accurate
dosing and to determine you know whether
or not a particular strain even has the
compound that you need some strains are
high in THC some strains are high in CBD
those are two examples of compounds
called cannabinoids but there's another
class called terpenoids those molecules
are what make a strain smell piney or
lemony or mango II but they could also
have an effect on how the plant makes
you feel and it's the synergistic
interaction between what would they call
the entourage effect the cannabinoids
that terpenes the flavonoids and
probably even some other things we
haven't even
really realize that really is important
to be able to say oh this strain is good
for this because of these things once
they do more about the chemical makeup
of each strain genetic mapping could
allow steep hill to work with leaders to
improve their strains chemical testing
and profiling it and and genetic testing
is of vital importance because it allows
us to understand the plant in a way that
allows us to treat as a as a bonafide
medicine